much football do you watch a week I  watch I watch two games on Sunday I tape  three right then I watch the Monday game  and then Tuesday I watch one of the  three that I taped Wednesday I watched  another one then I watched the Thursday  night game and then Friday I get to  watch the Sunday night game Saturday I  watch college football okay and it's  fine okay because I have a simple male  brain  that could just sit there and just just  enjoy it I can just enjoy it so so does  your wife watch any of these games with  you does she she has the female complex  multitasking prank  that's why they can't be happy they just  they just always been like what is that  lizard that can look at two things at  once that's what they like